我们今天讲原生家庭啊
其实我不想一上来就谈情绪
谈创伤或者谈父母
对不对首先呢
我想带大家回到一个地方
叫做自然界
就是你也别先急着对号入座啊
就是先跟我一块看一件事儿
人类其实是整个自然界里边儿
最脆弱的幼崽之一
你想一想一个孩子刚出生的时候
他能干嘛
对吧不能吃不能走
连自己上厕所都不行
而且不能判断危险
甚至连冷热他都分不清
他唯一会做的一件事只有什么
只有哭
而且不是哭着求生
是哭着等人来救
就是你把一个刚出生的
这么一个人类的婴儿
放在森林里边
我跟你说
你连一天都不用等几个小时
他都活不了
但是你把一只小鹿啊
一只小马
一只小羊放在自然里边呢
他们可能几个小时以后就能站起来了
对吧就能走路了
就能找妈妈了
甚至可以开始觅食了
所以一开始啊
人类他就不是一个靠本能活着的物种
人类是什么
人类是一个必须依赖关系依赖环境
依赖他人才能够存活的物种
那这件事
和我们后来一辈子的
这么一个心理的模式
有着非常非常深的关系
那今天我们就来聊一聊这个话题
原生家庭生命的孵化器
欢迎大家来到松明讲心理的频道
那么刚刚进来的同学
或者是第一次啊
刷到我们直播间的同学
可以加一加我们这个直播间的关注点
亮上方的这个灯牌啊
加一加咱们的粉丝团每天都来听一听
那今天讲的是一个非常基
础但是
和每一个人的生命息息相关的
这么一个话题啊
我们经常说原生家庭很重要
那么到底对吧
为什么原生家庭很重要
是不是
大家早上好啊
大家可以一边点赞一边来听一听啊
一边点赞一边听一听
人类为什么生下来就这么弱呢
其实在这我们稍微延伸一点
这种自然科学的知识啊
也是为了帮助我们更加好的理解自己
就是你们知不知道啊
其实从严格意义上来说
到目前为止
我们所有的人
你跟我都是早产儿
可能很多同学啊
一听这句话会愣这么一下
对吧我不是足月出生的吗
我怎么成了一个早产儿啊
我跟你说
原因很简单
因为人的头实在是太大了
哈哈
大到什么程度
你们看 200万年以前
人类就慢慢的开始直立的行走了
对吧一旦直立行走
女性的盆骨就必须变窄
否则她走不了路啊
可是与此同时
人类的大脑却在飞速的进化
尤其我跟你们说
是一个非常重要的部分
叫做前额叶
大家把前额叶三个字打一打来
前额叶三个字啊
前额叶很重要啊
前额叶是什么
就是负责你的理性
你的判断
你的计划
包括这种延迟满足
还有这种情绪的管理
自我控制的地方
换句话来说
就是成为人的这么一个关键的部位
那前额叶一发育对吧
你的头就会越来越大
骨盆就会越来越小
那这在自然界里边
它本来是一个很冲突的结构
就像刚刚有
的同学说
这不科学啊
所以说
自然法则啊
它只做一件事
就是它会让孩子提前出生
不然不然母亲就会有这个生命危险
于是人类的进化
就选择了一条非常特殊的路
就先把孩子生出来
再慢慢的长完整
那这也是为什么
你看很多孩子出生的时候啊
你们发现那个头顶是软的对吧
他前额叶是凸出来的
那不是说没有发育好
那是还在继续发育
那问题就来了呀
既然提前生出来了
那没长好的部分咋办呢
我跟你们说
答案只有一个
就是放进一个孵化器里边儿
这个孵化器
不是那个医院里边儿的机器啊
这个孵化器呢
我们把它叫做原生家庭
就一个孩子啊
他在出生后的前三年
本质上都是在完成
原本应该在母体里边完成的
这么一个进化的过程
所以你会发现
这个阶段的孩子
他几乎是无法脱离照料的
他得靠这种依附来活着
靠被回应活着
靠这种被抱着
被看见被安抚来完成大脑的发育
那你再对比一下
自然界里边的其他动物
我跟你们说
很多哺乳动物啊
一出生它就能跑
对吧
很多的卵生动物
妈妈把卵一产哎
直接就走人了
就是小生命自己面对这个世界
它是适者生存的
但人类不行
因为人类不是靠肌肉和本能来称王的
人类是靠大脑和关系来称王的
你们知道
我们现在住的这么一个地球
已经存在了大概有47亿年
就仅仅一个恐龙
就在地球上存活了1.65亿年
而人类从真正意义上的能直立行走
出现这种完整的头盖骨
我告诉你也不过200万年
真正有文字记载的文明史
可能才5,000年左右
所以你放在地球这么一个尺度上来看
人类其实是一个极其年轻
极其来的很晚的物种
那问题来了呀
一个又年轻对吧
幼崽又脆弱
体力又不占优势的物种
凭什么成为了地球的主宰呀
其实答案就在这
因为人类学会了在关系当中成长
就是人类的大脑
必须在关系当中才能完成发育
人类的心智必须在被回应当中
才能慢慢的成熟
你包括人类的文明
本质上
就是这种代际之间的心理的传递
而这一切的起点
就在你出生后的那个地方
原生家庭
所以什么才叫做真正的健康啊
那我给大家说
身体健康并不等于心理健康
你看咱们现在一说健康
大多数人的第一反应就是体检报告
对吧
血压呀血脂啊血糖啊
包括维生素
钙
蛋白质矿物质
这些重要吗
当然重要
但如果只有这些
你可能只是活着
不一定活得好
那心理健康呢
心理健康不是说你没有得抑郁症
心理健康就是说
你能不能安住在自己的身体里边
你能不能信任关系
你能不能在亲密关系当中不失去自己
你能不能在冲突里边不崩溃
你能不能在压力下调节情绪
而这些能力并不是你长大后学会的
他们几乎全部都是来自于你3岁之前
在原生家庭的这个孵化器里边的体验
所以
一个健康的原生家庭给
孩子提供的从来都不只是说吃饱穿暖
它真正提供的是第一个东西
叫做安全感
就这个世界对吧
是可以被信任的
那么第二个叫做稳定感
关系是连续的
不会随时的崩塌
那么第三个叫做被回应感
哎我的情绪是有人在意的
第四个是自我感
就是我可以是我
你可以是你
自我感就是我不是为了取悦而存在的
那还有一个叫做边界感
就是我可以是我
你可以是你
而一个功能失调的原生家庭
他并不一定一定非要有家暴啊
或者是离婚
或者是非常的穷
不是我跟你说
更多时候
他只是情绪长期得不到回应
爱有条件控制多于理解否定多于
看见
孩子他就会被迫提前懂事
那这种家庭
他不会把孩子杀死
但是会让孩子带着伤活下去
很多人来找我咨询的时候也会问
老师啊我是不是太敏感了
老师啊为什么我总没有安全感
老师我为什么一亲密就想逃
老师我为什么那么怕被否定
但你要知道一件事情
这些反应很少是你的性格不好
它往往就是你在那个孵化器里边
学会的这种生存的方式
这个方式当年救过你
但现在
有可能他开始限制你
所以我想说一句很重要的话
就是我们今天讲原生家庭
并不是为了去控诉父母
也不是说我们要沉溺在过去
你看
理解原生家庭的意义只有一个
就是我们要把人生的主动权啊
慢慢的给拿回来
是吧
当你看懂了
你并不是天生就脆弱
你只是来
自一个需要被理解的
这么一个孵化的过程
当你明白你现在的模式
是曾经为了活下去而形成的智慧
那我告诉你
你就不会在一边责怪自己
一边重复旧的命运
所以原生家庭
是我们每一个人的第一件温室
有的人他在温室里边就长得很好
有的人在温室里边他就被冻伤过
或者是枯萎过
但是我希望大家记住一件事
哪怕你长大之后啊
你都有机会为自己建造第二个孵化器
那这个孵化器是什么
就是觉察疗愈需求价值
大家看到我们上面四个词没
这就是我们的第二个孵化器
你的人生
不必永远停留在出生的那一站
你看我们现在已经知道了
科学已经证明了
在妈妈的肚子里边
对吧
很多时候这孩子已经开始受教育了
就是妈妈的这种思想
包括她的行为
包括她的心态
我告诉你对胎儿都有很大的影响
那我也相信
学了心理学的朋友也知道
一个妈妈
如果没有得到她自己母亲的爱
她其实很难真正的去爱自己的女儿
你看
现在也有越来越多的科学证据在证明
为什么呢
因为胎儿在妈妈的肚子里边
妈妈怎么想
他就怎么想
他就会怎么去感受
如果说
妈妈在心里边一直有这么一个念头
说我妈妈不爱我
那胎儿也会在里边形成一种结构
我妈妈不爱我
你看这不是讲道理啊
这就是潜意识结构的复制
然后这种胎中的教育
一直到出生的这个过程
我们刚刚也说过
在人类的
历史里边生产它是一道坎
很难过的关
1000年前500年前
我告诉大家
其实死亡率是很高的
因为这个过程很容易造成一种创伤
而且是各种各样的创伤
出生之后在家庭里边对吧
我离开了父母
我独立的存在
跟父母跟保姆的关系
跟爷爷奶奶外公外婆的关系
跟兄弟姐妹的关系
有兄弟姐妹年龄差距小于2年的
很多情况下都普遍会出现问题
为什么
为什么会出现问题啊
一个是资源
一个是关注
一个是比较
一个是竞争
一个是边界的混乱
他都会沉到你的沉
他都会沉到你的潜意识里边
变成这种人格的策略
然后我们长大积累了一些经验
往往就不知不觉
因为他们都这样做
所以我也这样做
这就是一种集体的无意识
我跟你们讲一个案例
有一个广州的老师上我的课
他就问啊
他说松明老师
我们班上有个男孩子啊
总是讲脏话
广州叫出口是吧
上课也讲
他说那我有什么办法
我说这个你不太容易搞啊
因为他家里的父母也是这样
是不是
他老师就说是啊
他们家里的人就是这样
那我就说
那你更没有办法了
因为在孩子的心灵里边
你没有办法比他的父母更高
就是他一定在潜意识里边
要证明他是隶属于这个家庭的
就父母怎么做
他一定会怎么做
这不是道德问题
这叫做归属本能
大家把这4个字打一打
归属本能
那怎么办呢
我觉得你唯一的方法
就是让这孩子明白
对吧在学校在有
同学的这么一个系统里边
如果他这样
他可能得不到其他人的尊重
就是让他能产生一种感觉
可能你没资格在我面前这样
于是孩子可能会做到在学校不讲
但是他离开学校还是会讲粗口
你看这
已经是系统切换能力的
这么一个雏形了
很多人他并不明白什么叫创伤
他会觉得这么一点轻微的小事对吧
可能就一句话而已
至于吗
但我想告诉大家
事情大或小
一句轻或重
这是理性的批判
但是创伤是在这里的
这个地方是没有数量的
对吧你就比方说爱情
我问你多少钱一斤啊
没得算嘛
创伤也一样
对成年人来说没什么事
对吧但是对婴儿
对小孩对很小时候的人
在他那个状态里边
我跟你们说一句话
就有可能成为很严重的创伤
成年人都会这样啊
这是不讲道理的呀
所以我们每一个人
都是在成千上万的创伤里成长的
但大多数咱们都意识不到
但是你会发现哎
为什么我对某些东西特别的敏感呢
那我告诉你
往往就是创伤遗留在提醒你
你比方说啊
我对穿这种红色衣服的男孩
我特别的敏感
我看到就会紧张
为什么
很有可能你一岁的时候
有一个穿红色衣服的男士打了我哥哥
我恰好在旁边看见了
就这么简单
可是他会变成一个什么
我们把它叫做警报器
这就是潜意识
他不会管你现在懂不懂
他只会管你当时安不安全
我举个简单的例子
从a到b到c
其实你缺的不是努力
而是中间这条路
我们都希望长大以后能做到c
对吧
能够稳定
能够成熟
能够幸福
能够成功
能够会处理关系
会做选择
会有贡献
但很多人忽略了
从a到b到c
中间有一个过程
你要培养一些基础的条件
你才能够做到c
否则你就是闭着眼睛走路
但是你闭着眼睛走路
老天他不会保证给你一条好路
对吗
你孩子同样也是啊
你要帮他培养一些能力
能够确保他将来成年以后
真的过得好一点
轻松一点
满足每天
对吧快乐
得到尊重
甚至是对社会有贡献
所以我今天想跟大家讲的就是这些
不然的话
我们的成长
他就是迷迷糊糊的
不知不觉就走上了一条路
是不是走到哪算哪
遇到事可能就爆炸
遇到挫折可能就崩溃
我不知道大家最近翻新闻
有没有一种感觉
每天都有一些事
让你心里边一凉
你就会奇怪呀
为什么有人
会做出这么不可思议的事儿
有的伤害了自己
有的还伤害了别人
有时候你的第一反应会想
是不是神经病啊
是不是精神有问题啊
可是更可怕的就是
很多人过去看起来很好
什么问题都没有
他突然之间就会变成这样
你甚至忍不住会去想
会不会就在你身边的人里边
也许也有这么一个
明天就会出现这种情况
你看现在很多地方
大大小小的问题越来越多
包括学生
亲生的好像越来越多
还有老师打学生
我记得前段时间我
看到一个新闻
某个地方幼儿园的校长
用那个火钳烫那个幼儿
对吧还有几个月前
有一个做官的打父亲
还有一个江西某地也是做官的
妈妈九十岁活活的给饿死了
今天还刷到一个
好像是老婆出轨
拿刀把这两个男的给捅死了
所以各位
你们想一想
我们活在了一个什么样的世界里边
我们不一直觉得自己是礼仪之邦吗
我们的道德伦理不是更好吗
那为什么会这样
那你可能会说
那国外也有问题啊
对吧他们也有问题
那那为什么我们也越来越乱
为什么冲突越来越多
社会里边出来的越来越多的这种对吧
矛盾大大小小生活里边到处都是
所以你问我的话
我把它们统称为一个词
这个词叫做心理健康
那我们今天不是说
来给大家来做这种道德裁判
不是我们也不是来评判谁是好人
谁是坏人
那我们今天要做的是
把这些现象我们往底下再挖一层
挖到能力
这一层
很多时候你以为是坏
其实是缺
缺的不是这种道德的口号
缺的是一些生存的能力
我刚刚讲的这几个真实的个案
我也是带着一份沉重的心情
但我不是说否定任何一个人的行为
也不是说他们坏
他们不行
我对他们也有一份尊重
因为我知道他们也不愿意那样做
只不过当时没办法
没办法
就是在当时的状态下
他选择了一个方式
然后这个方式后果太大
伤害了别人也伤害到了自己
所以我说这些东西是希
望大家能明白
假如在有选择的情况下
他们不愿意
同样
你跟我在某些情况
也可能做出错误的选择
但问题就在于
如何我们可以去减少这些因素
对吧
如何增加对事情更好的处理的能力
如果说
我们能从他们的遭遇里边学到东西
他们的命运
就能在我们的身上产生价值
所以用这个态度来看
我对他们是有尊敬的
而且他们也有父母
对吧他们也有家人
如果说是你家里边的孩子
你会非常的难过啊
没有父母愿意
自己的家里会发生这样的事
可是很多人他没有地方学
没有人提前告诉他们
对吧如果继续这样
6个月以后会发生什么
所以我们每天做的只有一件事儿
叫做预防心理学
大家把这5个字打出来
预防心理学不是出事后你再来哭
是现在咱们就把该补的能力给补起来
对吧
我刚刚说的这些个案
很多同学都知道吧
全国也有很多人知道吧
这类个案就有一个特点
就是父母充分的肯定或者认定
对吧我家孩子他不会干这事
直到事情发生
父母都根本不愿意接受
家庭也优秀
孩子也优秀
怎么会这样呢
那我现在问大家
你们有没有想过为什么他会这样啊
如果你是做心理辅导的
假设这事还没有发生
假设这时间可以倒流
你有机会在事情发生之前的6个月
辅导父母
或者辅导孩子
那我想问问你
你会提醒他们什么
他缺了什么
该补什么
该怎么做才能避免6个月后的
发生
但这就是我们今天谈的核心
不是道德的评判
而是能力的缺失
我们现在看一个成年人
真正要面对的是什么呀
情感关系对吧
婚姻关系亲子关系
怎么教孩子
怎么咱们可以让家庭和谐快乐
有成就对吧
学生的学习到工作哎
在职场里边做的多好
多不好
包括这种情绪压力的管理
能不能扛得住
人际关系
跟老板跟同事
跟顾客跟朋友怎么去相处
包括还有一个叫沟通能力
就是你话能不能说清楚
让别人明白
有没有这种说服力
对吧
生活里边什么该做
什么不该做
这事业怎么建立
创业怎么走
钱怎么赚
怎么守
包括我们性格里边的一些世界观
人生观什么重要什么不重要
怎么去排序
还有人格的发展
品德公民的意识社会的责任
奉公守法
你看我们开车
我看到很多老外来中国总是摇头
马路上大家都看得到嘛
对不对那这种次序感
这种规则感
这种尊重别人边界的能力
我们在哪个地方能学到呢
大家想过没有
我们成长过程
到底在哪培养这些东西啊
从有意识到有能力
再到做得出来
好像没有怎么被认真的教过
是不是这样
我们就这样差不多的长大了
一不小心就长大了
一不小心就做官了
一不小心就做了好官或者贪官了
一不小心就创业了
一不小心就几十个亿身家了
但我想问
生活快乐吗
有满足感吗
家庭和谐吗
跟孩子的关系好吗
我跟你们讲一个真实的案例
我有个朋友认识一个新东方的老师
就是被一个非常富有的人
聘请到他家去做家教
给儿子补习
这个老师一到家里边
就是屋子外里边啊
屋子外啊
屋子外边啊
几个大汉站在那当保镖的那种
你知道吧
那种富有就是你看一眼
你就知道他家有钱
孩子呢在学习
有一天这孩子就对这个老师说
他说老师
我很寂寞
你坐一会儿
你就多坐一会儿
陪我聊聊天
好不好
其实这个老师对这孩子呀
印象不太好
时间也到了
他就要走
他说不行
我要走了
我还有下一个补习的孩子
就说啊你不留下来你会后悔的
老师没不知道什么意思嘛
就没当回事
他真的不行
我明天我再来
第二天老师来了
不见了这个孩子
why
这个老师走了以后
孩子用小刀
刀片割腕了
所以各位同学
这个家庭富有到这样的地步
可孩子开心吗
亲子关系好吗
你说
我们到底追求的是什么呀
所以
如果这些是我们每个人追求的东西
关系
快乐
尊重成就满足
那我问问大家
我们在哪里可以学到
如果一不小心走错了拿错了
不是往上走
是往下在塌陷怎么办
人生最怕的不是不努力啊
我觉得人生最怕的就是
你努力
但底盘没有
你走得快
但系统没有
所以我们今天聊的也比较对吧
贴近我们的生活
我想请大家认真的去想一个问题
就是你从小学到大学十几年
咱们想一想啊
我们学到的东西
对一个人来说当然重要
但当你30岁40岁
这个时候
学校里边十几年学到的东西
对你每一天的生活的影响
占的百分比是多少啊
大家觉得是多少
我们打在评论区
让我看一看
你们觉得是多少啊
欢迎来到新来我们直播间的同学
没有加关注的
咱们加加松明老师的关注啊
咱们把灯牌都亮一亮
每天过来听一听啊
大家看看对吧
每一个同学打的答案
你们觉得我们在学校里边
十几年学的东西
在我们的生活里边的影响
占的百分比是多少
你觉得是多少
你就打在下面啊
你看有10%的 20%的
嗯
对吧
这是大家的理解嘛
有的同学说1%啊
嗯
而另外一个部分
我们如何来管理自己
如何解决问题
如何管理这种压力
如何照顾家庭
照顾自己
如何尊重尊敬别人
如何对世
如何对社会有贡献
事业上怎么走的更稳
更关键的是每天怎么快乐
怎么成功的过
你们觉得哪一方面
哪一块更重要啊
所以你问我我会说
这些东西
决定我们人生质量的重要程度
对人来说等于一个太平洋
是吧
而学校里边
我们学的那十几年
也许只是几杯水而已
可你再看看我们现在社会
为了这几杯水
我看到学生家长老师
甚至企业都纠结的不行
而那个太平洋
你想学你甚至都不知道去哪里学
这难道不是一种荒唐吗
这不是我们真正最重要的吗
所以我说
我们今天就活在了这么一个社会
那我一直在做一些研究
我发现我们确实可以做一些事儿
只不过
为什么要做怎么做
你看目前在很多地方这一块还是空白
所以在过去的3年时间里边
我把它们总结出来
那我今天在这也很荣幸
也有机会跟大家去分享
我们去年做了一个叫做五天的特训营
里边会讲到四个层面的唤醒
一个是讲个人
一个讲伴侣
一个讲孩子
一个讲家庭
特训营里边会教给大家很多的能力
这些能力往往简单到本能
就像本能就是本来轻松就能做到的
我们忽略了
没有注意
而且没有用
反过来我们忙别的
或者被错误引导走向了别的方向
但偏偏他们决定了人生的成败
我敢这么说
我觉得我们每个人都有
或多或少
包括我自己啊不是0
我觉得是不足够
就清醒的时候挺好的
有事一来就不行
对吧
可偏偏有事情出现的时候
你最需要的
我跟你们说
就是这份能力
这就好像什么呢
太阳出来的时候给你送把伞
有什么意思啊
对吧下雨的时候你才要伞
但问题就在于下雨的时候你没有伞
这就是问题啊
所以我们今天的这堂课
我们把定位讲清楚
不讲一些心理的疾病
我们讲的是心理的免疫系统
为什么
因为我觉得有病治病这件事对吧
社会已经越来越熟悉了
你身体不舒服
你去买就好了呀
买药就好了呀
严重一点你看看医生啊
更严重的你去医院
甚至做手术
如果你的心理的这种问题很严重
你可能会想到心理咨询
对吧心理辅导心理治疗
甚至精神科
但我今天要讲的是另一块
我们叫无病强身
无病强身
来大家把这4个字打一打
我想问大家一个非常简单
但是几乎没有人认真问过的问题
10个人里边也许有一个生病
9个没生病的
就是教会那9个没生病的
让他们不生病
不是更重要的事吗
对不对
你会发现
我们这个社会
对身体的这种无病强身很有办法
亚健康啊
锻炼啊补品啊
练功啊练各种东西
让自己好一点
对吧
这叫保养
这叫预防
这叫强身
这是身体层面
但心理层面呢
你不是精神病
你也没有被诊断
你也能上班
能结婚能带孩子
但你就是情绪越来越不稳
压力可能越来越扛不住
关系越来越容易炸
越来越容易躲
越来越容易崩溃
你想让自己好一点
你想让自己稳定一点
你想让自己在生活里边
活得像个人一点
那你去哪强身呢
我刚刚说过
这条路到现在为止还是很空白
所以今天我们要讲的就是把这块打开
唤醒心自我的特训营
就是为无病强身而存在的
他不是说等你出了事再救你
他是让你在出事之前
就拥有一套
能托得住自己人生的能力系统
一次彻底的心理唤醒之旅
每天都有作业
不是让大家写感想啊
是能直接落到你生活里的心理练习
我跟你们说
很多人包括一些老师
学心理学学了很久
都会卡在一个地方
就是没有人陪你把懂变成会用
而这一次
我们就是把这一块给补上了
我可以很坦白的告诉大家
这整套内容如果是在线下做
万元也是正常价格
我跟大家说
我们5天会围绕着一个关键词展开
叫做唤醒
就是把你那些长期自动运行
却一直在消耗你的心理系统的东西
一层一层的给唤醒出来
在心理学里边
一个人真正的改变
从来不是说我想通了
而是靠四个字意识上线
来大家我们把这四个字打出来
意识上线
第一层的唤醒个人成长
这是最重要的一件事
同学们
是不是个人成长
不是说我更要努力
我要有自律
我要更成功
不是
我跟你们说
在心理学里边
个人成长的第一步只有一件事
你和你自己的关系好不好
很多人的内在其实是塌陷的
就是他表面上看起来很正常
甚至很优秀
但他的内在是自卑的
自责的
充满着罪疚的
对自己极其苛刻的
天天在心里边骂自己的
甚至有些人会发展到自我攻击
有的会自残
有的情绪麻木
严重的甚至反复想过
就是我不想活了
这些不是说你不够坚强
同学们
这些
在心理学里边有一个非常明确的指向
就是内在关系的失调
大家把这几个字打一打
内在关系的失调
心理学里边有一个非常重要的观点
它会告诉你
人这一辈子
你真正要搞定的只有三段关系
第一段并不是人际关系
第一段就是你和你自己的关系
然后是你和他人的关系
最后是你和这个世界的关系
你看
排在第一位的
永远都是你和你自己
如果说你的内在啊
是一个天天被否定被批评
被打压的环境
你怎么可能在外在的关系里边
感觉到安全放松
有力量啊
是不是很多人都跟我说
松明老师
我就觉得自己哪都不够好
老师我一停下来就会自责
老师我好像永远都和在跟自己较劲
这不是你命不好
这就是你的内在系统里边
缺少一个稳定
支持自我接纳的内在父母
所以这五天营的第一层的唤醒
不是说教你变得更好啊同学们
而是带你重新建立一个
不再攻击自己的内在关系的结构
所以我经常问来访者这么一句话
我说
你愿不愿意和现在的自己做朋友啊
我也想问问直播间里边所有的同学
你们是怎么想的
你们愿不愿意和现在的自己做朋友啊
如果愿意的
我们打一个
愿意如果不太愿意
你就打不太愿意哈
就是你会发现
真的很多人
他心里边很拧巴
是不是
而一个人只要内在关系开始松
动他的外在世界
才可能有改变的可能啊
所以我经常跟大家说
记住一句话
我们要做价值的发现者
而不是毛病的放大镜
这就是非常核心的心理成长的原则
那么这是我们的第一层唤醒
第二层
唤醒两性关系家庭系统
就是
各位同学们注意
你这一辈子
时间最长
影响最深的关系
不是父母
也不是孩子
而是你的伴侣关系啊
对吧现实是什么
中国的离婚率现在已经多少了
其中将近百分之八九十
都是女性提出来的离婚
为什么
不是这个女人不想要家庭啊
而是他们在关系里边长期不被理解
不被看见
情绪没有得到回应
长期独自的承担沟通
只有指责冷漠或者是沉默
心理学的研究早就发现
在亲密关系的这种破裂
很少是事件问题
几乎都是关系系统的失效
很多人
他不来做心理的学习
不是说没问题
而是因为他觉得家丑不可外扬
他觉得说出来很丢人
但心理学要告诉你的是
你不说这问题他不会消失
他只会在关系里边
换一种方式继续
所以在这
我们今天开场的直播
就讲了非常重要的一个概念
叫做原生家庭的孵化器
什么意思呀
什么叫做孵化器
什么叫做库存呐
就是你自己小时候啊
没有被看见的这些委屈
没有被回应的情绪
或者是没有被允许的愤怒
没有被满足的需要
这些东西
他并不会因为说你长大了
他就自动消失
反而他们会进入到你的亲密关系
变成要求
变成指责控制失望冷战情绪爆炸
你以为你在和伴侣吵
其实
你是在替那个小时候没人管的自己
你在讨一个说法呀
所以我们直播间的所有同学
如果你们觉得自己的身上
有这种原声库存的话
可以打一句
我有原声库存
在这5天里面
我们会教给大家
如何去识别
家庭系统里面的一些隐形的角色
如何去区分当下的关系
和这种过去的投射
如何停止把旧伤继续丢给最亲近的人
那么第三层的
唤醒亲子关系
这是很多家长
都非常关心的一个东西
你看很多人开始学心理学
不是说因为自己想成长
而是因为孩子出问题了
是不是这样啊
有的厌学
有的沉迷游戏
有的焦虑
有的抑郁
有的自残
有的情绪失控
但心理学里边有一句非常重要的话呀
就是孩子的问题
往往不是孩子的问题
而是家庭系统里边有情绪没人接
有问题没人处理
这就是心理学里边的创伤代际传递
它就告诉我们
你没有处理好的伤不会消失
它一定会通过孩子的行为
被重新的给演出来
这个并不是说我们在指责父母
而是提醒大家
真正的育儿
是父母先完成自己的心理成长
所以
这5天里边
我们不只是教你怎么去管孩子
而是带你回到你自己的童年
你自己的情绪和你自己的未完成事件
你可以问问自己啊对吧
我小时候
有没有一些从来没有说出口的委屈
有没有
如果有
你可以在心里边默默的点一个头
你会知道孩子为什么他会替你表达
那么
第四层的唤醒
也是我们最重要
在5天特训里边叫做觉醒的自己
我们这一辈子有三个关键的转折点
第一个叫原生家庭
第二个叫亲密关系
第三个叫觉醒的自己
就这三个东西
这就是我们人生最重要的三个转折点
大家可以把它打出来
原生家庭亲密关系觉醒的自己
如果前两个你都已经受过伤了
那我告诉你
第三个
就是
你真正可以亲手去改变你命运的地方
觉醒它不是突然开悟
觉醒在心理学里边只有四个字
建立自我
你是谁你要什么
你擅长什么
你怕什么
你真正不能接受的是什么
很多人一辈子
都活在了别人的期待评价标准里
活成了一个功能正常
但是灵魂缺席的人
真正的觉醒是什么
我问问大家
大家觉得真正的觉醒是什么呀
你能听见别人的声音
但不被操控
你能看到自己的脆弱
但不再逃避
你开始为自己的人生负责
是不是
你会发现那些反复出现的痛苦
不是惩罚
而是提醒
你的心理作业还没做完
所以我跟大家说
这5天特训营的真正的目标
就是让你从无意识走向觉察
从内耗走向整合
从重复命运走向选择人生
那这就是一场彻底的心理的唤醒之旅
所以我想问直播间的同学一句话
你觉得你的人生已经开始觉醒了吗
如果你愿意走在路上
我们打四个字
我在路上
我问大家一个问题
你不用回答我
你问问自己就是
你有没有这种感觉
学过很多东西
听过很多的课
道理都懂
回到生活里边
情绪还是失控
关系还是卡住
人生还是在重复同一种类
如果你有的话
我想先告诉你一句话
不是你不努力
也不是说你悟性不够
而是你过去学的
大多是知道
却很少有人
真正的陪你走
一段改变正在发生的过程
这就是我们做
我们做的这个5天
唤醒新自我特训营的原因
它就是一段被陪着走完的5天
他负责的是什么
让你第一次真正的听懂潜意识
听懂情绪语言模式是怎么运作的
帮你去建立一套理解自己的底层地图
带着你一步一步
走进你真实卡住的地方
你会被一直陪着
被看见被回应
为什么是5天
我跟大家说很简单
人的改变
它不是发生在某一个瞬间
而是发生在连续几天
状态被稳定托住的时候
你们看看
简单看一看5天的这个内容
我简单跟大家说一说
很多同学今天第一次来
第一天我们讲你为什么活得这么累
就这个晚上
我们会一起拆解一个真相
你不是不行
是你一直用一个壳在活着对吧
你会看到
你现在的性格是怎么一步步形成的
为什么明明很努力
却总是在消耗
为什么你对别人很好
对自己很苛刻所以
第一天的重点不是分析别人
而是你第一次把我放回到心里边
很多同学上完第一天啊
都会告诉我
松明老师
我好像第一次站到自己这边了
第二天学会真正的爱自己
就是你会看到
我怎么习惯性的否定自己的
我怎么在心里边一次次抛弃自己的
你所谓的懂事
体谅背后到底牺牲了什么
在这个晚上
你会开始明白
爱自己不是自私
是你终于停止了对自己的攻击
第三天亲密关系
为什么走向痛苦
为什么你越在乎越容易失控
为什么你总是吸引到同一种人
为什么在关系里边
你不是委屈就是愤怒
你听完第三天
你会发现啊
原来我关系从来都不是选错人
而是你的内在模式
在关系里边不断的重演
很多人会在这一晚第一次放下对前任
对伴侣对父母的执念
第四天亲子关系
大多数父母的问题
其实不是不爱自己的孩子
是太焦虑太自责太用力
所以我们会一起看
控制唠叨焦虑背后的心理机制
对吧孩子的问题
究竟替谁在说话
父母怎样先稳住自己
关系才会改变
很多家长在这一天会哭
不是因为难过
而是松了一口气
第五天是觉醒的自己
就是你的人生要怎么继续
最后一天
我们并不是收尾
而是在打开了下一段的人生
你会非常清楚
什么是你真正要走的方向
什么是该放下的这种旧的模式
什么样的自己是更完整
更有力量的
那这一晚结束的时候
我觉得你会很稳
那它适合什么样的同学来听呢
如果我说的直接一点
情绪容易失控
内耗严重
在关系里边经常反复的受伤
明明很努力
越来越累
想真正的改变
而不是说我要听一堆的道理
那
这5天非常的适合你
我最后跟大家说一句掏心窝子的话
很多人不想不是不想改变
是太久没有人陪着他改变
对吧你看你一个人想事的时候
是不是总是越想越乱
越想越怀疑自己
最后又回到了原点
你会慢慢的发现一件事
当你不再一个人面对自己
很多原本很难的东西
都会开始慢慢的变轻
这5天里边
你不需要表现的很好
你也不用急着变厉害
你只需要真实的来
来感受
来觉察来发现
很多人都是在这种状态下
突然明白了一句话
我太久没有被理解了
如果你也有面对这样的问题
如果你听到现在
心里边有一点点松动
有一点点想给自己一次机会
我会很认真的邀请你加入
到这5天
你也不用想太多
我觉得你只需要问自己一句话
我愿不愿意用5天的时间
好好陪自己一次
如果答案是有一点点愿意
那我觉得就足够了
我们这5天一起走